i thought the timing of me talking to
you today was
really good because um you know they
announced something about a netflix
series called sandman
uh or my mistake what do you know about
it
have you heard it are you a fan of nil
neil gaiman
well i mean listen i don't want to get
you in any trouble because i know that
everything is you know
i'm not going to ask uh i guess i wish i
had some sunglasses man
um [ __ ] i had some somewhere
you know these are my logan sunglasses
um
yeah i yeah man we're doing it uh
we're doing the sandman we're shooting
it out in london
and um i played the corinthian which
uh is one of the uh
yeah coolest thing that's happened uh in
a while
to me uh to get to play this character
because i there's just
um yeah it's one of the good ones that
hasn't been done
and um it's like the last comp it's like
the
one of the best comic books that haven't
been made so it's um
it's exciting making it now is the
perfect time
because of the mixture of the audience
ability to
understand all this the visual effects
being what they are
and having something like somebody like
netflix who is willing to tell this
story
in an adult way um and so i guess what i
want to know is
uh how did you get the role was it
something you went after like talk a
little bit about how you got involved
it was a long process uh i
had heard that they were doing it i
heard i mean i've heard over the years
people were doing it you know i think
joseph gordon-levitt was
even going to try something to do
something and that would have been i
would love to see his version
um uh but i read the script
and they're really adamant about
everyone auditioning
so i i went in
i can't it must have been like
a year ago probably a year ago and then
and then i didn't hear anything for
until probably like
man september or something like that
anyways a long process
and then they uh the conversation just
started
um and then they wanted to to tape again
and they wanted to meet with neil which
i was really interested in doing and
talking just how the show was going to
be done
i had some you know i
just because the project gets greenlit
you know doesn't doesn't mean things are
going to go great yeah you kind of want
to
suss out and figure out who's involved
and how are you going to do things and
what's the approach um and to make sure
everything lines up and makes
sense to to do because you you know you
want to
neil hasn't done done this for 30 years
so you don't want to
you know lead with the wrong foot you
want to get the ship in the water and
point it
in the right direction from the get-go
because again that's something really
hard to reverse engineer
so yeah i'm really excited we um just
started
on london and we've got uh incredible
actors to work with and
to portray these characters when did so
you just started
filming recently yeah just before
christmas
i'll be there until uh june is this one
of these things when you sign on
that they say to you we have a three
season idea
we have a five season idea we you we
want you to know what we're
doing before you sign on because this is
not something that i envision is going
to fail
i envision this being a flagship on
netflix
something big so how much are they
telling you when you sign on
just know we have a five season plan
yeah i think everyone wants
a show to contin i think that's a
standard contract
i think seven five years
whatever um we have
talked about all that um i don't know if
it'll work out i think it might work out
in different blocks uh of time
but um yeah you definitely want to hear
how
you know how long something's going to
happen you want to have some sort of
macro idea of like how some how long
somebody's going to last
but um yeah i can't i don't really want
to give away the details of
how long completely the i guess what i
want to know is
uh you've obviously read the scripts and
i'm curious
you've read at least once no i read them
yeah yeah yeah i was going to say but
like for fans of the material
and obviously you're familiar with the
material now that you've signed on
what do you think for fans what can they
look forward to dave goyer's on it
allen heinberg is our show runner
um these guys know what they're doing
um howard our
directors jamie childs um
and um our other director of home i'm
totally blanking on right now he's gonna
kill me um
but yeah these guys are smart and
they're artists and they're craftsmen so
um
i think no one's leaving any stone and
turned on how
on what stories to incorporate and how
to weave them in together and how to
play this
you know storyline through um
i think what people are just going to
see this thing
uh realized is is transforming it
is is really what it's all about
you know making it it is a
hard show to to turn into reality you
know there's so much set
building and there's so much
design that goes into this um
so a lot of people are employed to
to get that done so um and with
such grandiose sets and all that stuff
you have to have a lot of people making
you know coming to an agreement on
decision